ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: I actually
just finished doing a
videotaped deposition for eight
hours about putting
Napster on download.com and
CNET, and writing tutorials on
how to use it.
So this is all very
fresh in my mind.
And in fact, the legal battles
are still going.
ALEX WINTER: Very
much so, yeah.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: So I thought
you did a great job
with the film.
It's a massively important
topic.
The internet only
happened once.
Peer to peer only showed up
for the first time once.
And they're both here
with us forever.
What do you see as the relevance
of the Napster story
to today's technology?
ALEX WINTER: Well,
I think a lot--
and I think it's a funny thing,
because in some ways
it's late for a Napster story.
In a lot of ways, it's too early
for a Napster story.
And I feel more on the latter
than I do on the former.
The heart of what Fanning
innovated and disrupted in
terms of his vision was about
looking at the internet as a
place where everybody could be
communally connected, and that
there would be a democratic
flow of information and
content and all connected by
people all over the world, and
sort of like the idea of
something that Google has
dealt with subsequently of
cataloging and indexing
everything.
I mean, the stuff that he was
interested in mostly was
firstly, the social community
aspect, and then the notion of
being able to find things
that were not
freely and easily available.
So I think that strikes
at the heart.
That's what I found interesting
about Fanning when
I first met him over
10 years ago.
That's what I found
interesting about
Napster when I used it.
And certainly, those, I think,
are the more prevalent issues
that are facing us today in
every corner of the tech
sector, whether it's Google,
YouTube, the issues around
that, some of the battles
that are being
fought there with Viacom--
who paid for this movie,
by the way--
and other people, all the way
to Arab Spring, and Bradley
Manning, and the NSA Snowden
scandal, and issues about
transparency, freedom of
information, internet rights.
These are things when Napster
erupted in '99 and I got onto
it, I'd gotten online in the
late '80s, and it was so
obviously a seismic shift, and
such a big rock in the water.
It was clear in '99
that the world was
never going to go back.
So we're still, as you said,
dead in the middle, if not
actually in the infancy of the
battles for the future that
are happening right now.
There's absolutely zero
resolution in sight, as far as
I can tell.
So that's why I think
it's relevant.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah.
My favorite saying that I've
coined about this, thank you
very much, was that the internet
is a perfect tool for
freedom or control.
And it seems like Napster was
on the freedom side of the
equation for sure, and it just
seemed incompatible with the
control part that now seems
to be happening
sometimes on the internet.
ALEX WINTER: Yeah.
And I think that something
that's really often overlooked
about Napster--
and I get this a lot, because
I've been talking about this
movie a lot since we made it and
went on the road with it--
the very first question I
always get in Q and As--
I wouldn't get it at Google, but
when I'm not dealing with
technology people is oh,
where can we download
this movie for free?
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: That's
my last question.
ALEX WINTER: Yeah.
And it always makes me laugh.
But it's sad, because my answer
is very mundane in that
Napster was never a piracy
service, and it wasn't created
as a philosophical
piracy service.
So your question is interesting,
because to me,
Napster sums up the duality of
the internet in one company.
Because they were
not Pirate Bay.
These were guys with
an ethos--
and there's things about Pirate
Bay that I love, so
it's not a pro or con thing.
But these were not anarchists
who were specifically out to
create a decentralized system
that would be unstoppable.
Quite the opposite.
They intentionally created a
centralized system, knowing
that in doing so, they had to
have some affiliations with
businesses.
They were not going to survive
as a company--
and they wanted to survive,
they wanted to make money,
they wanted to be a business--
if they couldn't do deals with
the labels and the various
interests whose content they
were moving around.
So here was a company that was
both at once about freedom of
the internet, and
also required a
certain amount of control.
And I think that because of that
need, especially at that
era of the internet, there was
no way that they would ever
have survived, because they were
trying to bridge-- the
people that survived
were people like,
say goodbye to control.
We're all about freedom, and
you can basically kiss our
backsides, because we don't
really want to do
business with you.
And hopefully, we'll
dismantle you.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
So in your mind, after speaking
to everybody,
interviewing everybody that you
interviewed in the film,
which is a huge breadth of
people, was it ever your
impression that the so-called
legal Napster that was a
subscription service--
did that ever
really stand a chance?
Did anybody think that?
ALEX WINTER: I know a lot of
people very much did think
that it would stand a chance,
because there were some very
powerful businesspeople who
were working tirelessly to
make a subscription service.
Did Fanning and Parker and Ali
Aydar and the core Napster
guys think--
I mean, it's questionable.
I don't want to make people
angry in retrospect by saying
what I think about that.
But I think it's questionable.
I think that they realized by
the time they got around--
because you have to remember
that once you're injuncted,
you can't innovate.
You can't do any R and D. You
can't do any work on the
product at all.
So they were baked in lucite
at a certain point by the
legal system.
Once that happened, a lot of
them just felt like the game
was up no matter
what they did.
And it went on like
that for years.
I remember when I first met
Fanning as Napster was
crumbling, and I said to him,
what to you was the highest
high you had on this
whole process?
When was the greatest moment?
He said, everything was great
until I hit send and
uploaded the app.
He goes, everything up until
then was awesome.
He says from the moment he
uploaded it, within a very
short period of time,
he realized
that they were screwed.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
And it is a shame that there
still isn't really a great way
to access all that stuff.
I mean, the way that I
used to use Napster--
I would pretty much just search
for Mogwai that I was
really into, and then if anybody
had them, I would know
that anything else they
had, I would be
probably into that too.
Nobody who just is only into
Metallica is going to have a
Mogwai song.
And so it's like, that
was my litmus test.
And then it's like, oh, here's a
live Mogwai show, and here's
some band that's not even on a
label that sounds like that.
Might have been an Explosions In
The Sky song in your movie.
So it seems like there still
isn't anything like that.
And what was it, 60
million users
Napster had at some point?
So Spotify right now, which
is the biggest on demand
subscription service, has
not even half that
worldwide in 2013.
I think SoundCloud has more
users than that, but nobody
makes any money from that.
So do you think that
there's a chance?
Can copyright ever possibly be
reformed to the point where
there can be an all you can eat
Napstery service that has
all the grey area files?
ALEX WINTER: You know, I don't
think we have a choice.
I think that the sad truth of
it is, a lot of people wish
that a lot of things
would go away.
I think that there are people
that wish that people would
stop legislating against
innovation on the one side.
I think on the other side, there
are certain sectors of
the industry that just wish
the internet would go away
completely.
I think the reality of it is
that we have no choice but to
reform copyright.
Now, frankly, in my opinion,
copyright desperately needs to
be reformed anyway.
It's Byzantine, and it's built
around pre-existing systems
that aren't even relevant
anymore and haven't been for a
very long time, for
the most part.
So I think that we currently
live in a world where neither
the consumer or the artist
is being well served.
So I think copyright law
desperately needs to be reformed.
And I think that frankly,
YouTube is the only example I
can think of an online service
where you have an opportunity
to find content that isn't
freely available.
That's the closest thing, in a
way, to what Napster had in
that it's a searchable
database.
But the difference being,
obviously, that-- and this is
all going to change
and evolve--
is that it doesn't yet have the
curation component that
Napster had in '98, '99, where
it was very easy, like you
just said about Mogwai, to drill
down and find the stuff
you were looking for that led
you to more stuff that you
were looking for.
It was kind of a fractal-like
experience.
I remember for me, because I'm
a jazz fan, I was immediately
after rare and unreleased
jazz bootlegs.
That was my Napster thing.
And I was able to drill down and
drill down and drill down
and just find unbelievable stuff
very, very, very quickly
over dialup.
That does not exist right
now in any service.
But it's coming, and copyright
notwithstanding, it's coming.
So we have to reform the laws to
catch up to the technology.
I mean, as Ron Conway says in
the movie, you can't stop the
technology.
You can't.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: It's true.
I mean, I view file sharing as
kind of a pressure valve on
the legal services.
Like, if they don't get it
right, everybody's going to go
back to Napster.
And of course, there's
BitTorrent sitting there.
And some of these are
still around.
But to me, it seems like really,
it's kind of worked as
a pressure valve.
I mean, would there be
a Spotify had there
never been a Napster?
Let's maybe talk about
this a little bit.
So in your film, there's
this idea that--
I forget who said it, but
there's Napster led to
Friendster, Friendster begat
MySpace, MySpace begat
Facebook and Google+ and
everything else.
So do you buy that?
Do you think Napster is like
the granddaddy all of these
social services?
ALEX WINTER: Well, I'm just
a guy who made a movie.
So sure.
In my opinion, absolutely,
because that's what I
experienced with my relationship
to technology.
That was how it worked for me.
I can tell you that everybody
that I know in the tech sector
feels that way.
Everybody I've met super high
up the food chain in that
world all credit
Fanning with--
I mean, there are sort of
grumbly, mumbly people as
competitive as everybody can
be who are just like,
obviously, this would have
happened at some point.
It was coming.
But I think what you can't take
away from those guys was
their ability to scale that
service, which had not been
done before.
Their ability to get it
to 60 million users.
Their ability to move content
around that quickly in the age
of dialup was radically
innovative.
And also, the sheer disruptive
nature of what Fanning and
Parker put out there.
And you can argue--
I went to great pains to not get
bogged down in the ethics
discussions in the movie.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah, how
do you respond to that?
ALEX WINTER: Because I feel
very, very strongly that the
world that we live in,
especially with the way the
media works and the news media
works in this day and age,
things get very quickly
mythologized.
And I think that once they
do, you lose specificity
completely.
And to me, the Napster debate
always being focused around
this notion of piracy versus
artists rights or the
industry's rights was so
specious and inaccurate, and
caused, I think, an extra 10
years of not understanding
what was really going on.
The fact that we're still in
court arguing over various
clauses of the DMCA in 2013 just
says to me that nobody,
for the most part, has any idea
what the hell is actually
going on, how to solve it.
And I think it's irresponsible
to just keep creating this
very buzzworthy debate about
kids in baseball caps who want
to steal shit and the
man who's trying to
hold onto the product.
I just think it's irrelevant.
And I think that the reality of
the world we're in is that
the technology has happened.
A lot of really innovative
people are driving it forward.
A lot of people are
trying to stop it.
And the fact is, as you just
said, it's going to evolve
with or without this
legislation.
So the best thing we can
possibly do is stop bickering
about the ethics and go,
guess what, guys.
We live in this world now.
Let's start working out ways of
serving the consumer, the
artist, various people, and
getting the laws adjusted that
we need to get adjusted rather
than criminalizing people and
pointing fingers at who may or
may not be right or wrong for
wanting to download something,
either for free or for less
money than somebody wants
it to be spent on.
I just think it's irrelevant.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: So what do
you think about artists--
I mean, there a few that--
I guess Thom Yorke is the
most notable one--
who are opting out of the quote
unquote "legal services"
that have descended
from Napster.
I mean, Spotify uses peer
to peer technology.
Shawn Parker's involved.
It's free if you want
it to be in the US.
And what's your take on artists
that are just saying,
no, we don't want that either.
ALEX WINTER: I think, in a
way, all of it's good.
Like, I have my own opinions
about Thom Yorke's response to
Spotify, that a lot of people
like Bob Lefsetz have
responded to very articulately
in that you can take it off
Spotify, yet it's still
on YouTube.
So it doesn't make a lot of
sense from a technological
standpoint.
I think that the argument that
artists need to be fairly
compensated is valuable.
I think it was valuable with the
record industry before the
technologies, and I think it's
valuable in this new landscape
we live in.
I think people fighting
for artists--
I'm an artist.
People fighting for the rights
of artists are good people.
So I think that, again, I'm
really against creating black
and white out of gray.
So I think we live in
a world of gray.
I think that people are going,
OK, so you're innovating over
there, Spotify.
Well, that's cool, but we don't
like X, Y, and Z. So
Spotify can respond and maybe
fix some aspect of X, Y, and
Z.
So I think the democratization
of these evolutionary
technologies to the degree that
they can be democratic is
a good thing.
It's better than shutting
people up.
I don't always agree with
them, but I'm happy for
someone to heckle someone is
trying to build something.
You might make them build
a better mouse trap.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Well, that's
a very mature way of
looking at.
I think back then, everyone--
ALEX WINTER: Yeah, I'm old.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: I guess we
all are, a little bit more
than back then, because
it really was a
black and white thing.
It was like, for us or against
us, and very ideological.
And I think it is helpful
that a lot of people
have gotten past that.
And I got a press release the
other day about I guess you
can now back up your phone using
peer to peer technology
to your own computer.
Like, your own peer, and somehow
bounce it around in
secure packets or something.
And anyway, it seems like now
it's coming out that there are
many, many legitimate uses for
this technology as I recounted
at length during my recent
videotaped deposition.
So, shifting gears a bit,
first, let me go here.
We had a 16-year-old intern
where I work, and he's coming
from a very different place.
He's what they call
in your film a
digital native, I guess.
And he said that when he's
assigned work in school, to
read something, that literally
nobody actually
reads the book anymore.
I mean, even with Shakespeare
or something, it's like, it
wasn't even Cliff Notes.
It's Spark Notes or something is
what they're all using now.
And his question to me
was like, what are
you going to do?
How are you going to write long
form stuff to people like
me who are never going
to read it?
And I was like, hmm, yikes.
Do you see the documentary or
the video form as the new long
form journalism, or is this
how more complicated
information is going
to be relayed?
ALEX WINTER: I don't.
I honestly don't.
I really, really don't.
And I've got three kids, and my
three year old will sit in
front of a magazine and
try to move the screen
like it's an iPad.
So I get that the world
is changing.
But I've been saying this
for years within
my own content unions.
I'm in four different unions,
and there's a sky is falling
mentality that I just think is
so completely erroneous.
And I think that, yeah, change
hurts some people.
Innovation causes disruptions,
which causes certain aspects
of our lives to change.
But if there's one thing we've
learned in the last 150 years
of massive, accelerated change
is there's room for many
different types of people, and
many different platforms.
And the radio is going to kill
the newspaper, and the movie
was going to kill the radio, and
TV was going to kill the
movie industry, and Betamax was
going to kill the movies,
and downloading music
was going to
kill the music industry.
And it's all nonsense.
And it just keeps getting proven
over and over and over
again to be nonsense.
But it's like one more person
talking about why
write novels anymore?
It's like, go on the subway.
People are reading novels.
My kid, who's 14, 15, is a
voracious novel reader.
He reads novels faster
than I do.
He reads all of them.
You know what I mean?
So I don't think it's
going away.
I think that the world's
filled with people.
There's lots of people in this
world, and there are many
different types of people
in the world.
And they like consuming their
stuff in different ways.
And you've this one kid who's
like, maybe he's got ADD.
I don't know.
But he doesn't want to read
anything that's long.
I don't either, and I'm an old
guy, you know what I mean?
So I may be more like him by
nature, and the technologies
are serving me in many ways that
I like, because I do like
doing a lot of different
things at
once, as opposed to--
But I think it's a temperament
issue, and I just think the
world we live in now offers you
that many more outlets for
consuming whatever culture you
want however you want.
I think that the fact that print
media is beginning to
respond to these changes as
well as they have, when
everyone thought they'd be the
first place to go under--
like, completely.
Why the hell would you ever
read a newspaper again?
Well, people are reading
them in various forms.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Well, there
you go with that nuanced
viewpoint again, where it's
not one or the other.
And I actually think
as a writer, text
does have its place.
I think it's actually, in terms
of the information per
minute, it doesn't do
badly against other.
I mean, it depends what you're
trying to present.
About the documentary process.
So, I mean, I think we can
both agree that it's
important, whether or not it's
going to replace other long
form information relay
techniques.
So I'm sure there are people
watching this that have had an
idea to do a documentary about
a phenomenon that's important
the way that Napster is, was.
How does one go about
doing this?
You've got so many people on
camera that were just involved
with this from the start.
How do you do this?
What do you do?
I'm sure it's really
easy, right?
ALEX WINTER: Well, like I said,
I started working on
this project in '02.
I wrote it as a narrative for a
major studio in '03 and '04.
It went into turnaround, which
means it was just sitting in
development, and
I walked away.
I came back to it in '09, and
I decided to make it a doc,
because I felt like there were
so many prevalent issues in
Napster's story that would be
better served having the
original people talk about it
than me putting words in their
mouth as a narrative.
The fact is that documentaries
are in a golden age.
I think that because-- and this
is going to sound very
buzzwordy, but they are like
a multi-platform media.
For instance, with Downloaded,
our distribution rollout is
theatrical, nine different types
of digital, streaming,
free streaming, ad aggregated
streaming, downloadable,
whatever, on all
these portals.
They're a good, present
day piece of content.
They are hard to get
made, because
they're hard to monetize.
I mean, documentaries are tough
to monetize, so you have
to really find people who just
want to tell the story and get
the story out there.
But they exist, and there are
more of them now than there
ever have been.
I mean, for all the kvetching
people do in my industry about
how much worse things are now,
there's way more opportunity
now than there ever was in terms
of the amount of buyers
and the amount of content
distribution networks.
I mean, there's more popping up
every day via the net, via
conventional TV, or whatever.
So I think if you have an
interesting enough idea and
you're willing to stick with
it, I think you have a good
chance of getting
something made.
The other beauty about a doc
is you can just make it.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: True.
ALEX WINTER: I mean, you could
just make it and then
distribute it yourself, or build
into the structure of it
later with the financing.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: That's an
interesting way to do it.
Sort of cart before the
wagon, but who cares?
ALEX WINTER: In this day and
age, I mean, that's it.
There's no cart or
wagon anymore.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
Yeah.
I meant horse cart, but yeah,
I take your point.
So I had an interesting day
around this whole time that
the film is about.
So I was sitting there at CNET,
and there were a bunch
of people from News.com.
John Borland, who had a
story in here, and a
bunch of other reporters.
And we had Hilary Rosen in the
room, from the RIAA, right, I
think, during the end
of her tenure.
And we grilled her for, I don't
know, an hour or two
hours, 20 reporters, all
recording things in her face.
And she was very
nice about it.
I was surprised that she didn't
actually breathe fire
after everything I'd
heard about her.
So we all peppered her with
questions forever.
And then at the end of it, she
goes, now I have one question
for all of you.
What would you do
if you were me?
And we were like, oh, gosh.
So she's got the labels going
after her on one side, and
then she's got the entire
internet mocking her on the
other side.
And I think in your
film, she comes
off as kind of agreeable.
But what would you have done?
Say that you're Hilary Rosen
around this time.
What do you do?
ALEX WINTER: Well, if I'm Hilary
Rosen, and I'm working
for a trade organization that
represents an industry that's
in a battle, and I'm being paid
handsomely by that trade
organization, I fight for my
trade organization or I leave.
And I don't mean to be glib.
I think the facts speak
for themselves.
She left eventually.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: She did, and
she left, notably, before
they started suing
actual fans.
ALEX WINTER: I think she left
specifically before they
started suing individual fans.
And I think they're all in
a very tough position.
I think the labels are
in a tough position.
I think that the RIAA is still
The one thing I'm not--
I'm certainly gray, but
I'm not cavalier.
There's two things that happen
in any kind of revolution like
this, whether it's cultural
or political.
It's sexier to side
with the new guys.
You know what I mean?
And you feel like the winner if
you side with the new guys.
So I think psychologically, I
always try to tug against that
inclination within myself to
just go, yeah, this is cool
and it's new, so I'm just
going to side with this.
I think that there are things
that have to get worked out,
and I think that it is incumbent
upon the new leaders
in the space--
which is predominantly Google,
to be completely honest, at
this point in time--
to really very carefully
navigate this terrain.
I don't think it's
easy for them.
I don't think it's easy for the
pre-existing businesses.
I don't think it's easy
for the artist.
To some degree, I don't think
it's easier for the consumer,
because they're going, Jesus, am
I a criminal if I do this?
Am I actually breaking
the law?
But I want to do it, and
everyone's telling me to do
it, and it's definitely more
convenient and a better system
than this creaky old one they're
trying to bend me to
go back into.
I would say that we're
all Hilary Rosen.
I think everybody's facing these
very tough choices right
now every day.
I think that what's really
interesting--
not to try to elevate the
Napster story beyond where I
think it deserves to go,
but I think there's
a correlative between--
I mean, look at what's going
on with the Syria decision.
You now have the democratization
of information
to do to a degree that you've
never had it before.
So you've got the government
saying, oh, no, no.
We've got to do.
And everyone's behind us.
And everyone's going,
well, no we're not.
Now, in the past, you wouldn't
hear everybody
saying no or not.
There would no way to hear that
voice other than at the
water cooler.
Now we know that there are tens
of millions of people out
there via social media saying,
well, actually, no, we don't
really want to bomb Syria.
Now Obama's Hilary Rosen.
Everybody's now stuck
in this position of
just going, oh, crap.
How do we deal with the fact
that on the one hand, we need
to have control, and on the
other hand, there's this all
of this freedom of
information?
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
So it seems like--
this was going to be one
of my questions.
Do you view peer to
peer technology
as inherently political?
It sounds like yes.
ALEX WINTER: I think everything
is inherently
political, because look how
quickly the peer to peer issue
became political.
I mean, I saw it
coming in '99.
To me--
and Fanning said it himself
the day I met him.
He said that Napster has nothing
to do with music, and
I got that completely when
I got on Napster.
It was like, it could've
been anything.
The idea to move music around in
a way was a delivery system
for Shawn, because he
knew that that was
like the pied piper.
That would get the kiddies
to come to the party.
The party is what mattered.
The party was the end
game, not the lure.
So of course it was going to
get political, and it got
political very, very quickly.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Indeed.
So I was one of these people
who was a big believer in
SNOCAP, and followed it all
the way to its end.
I forget who acquired it, and
it kind of fizzled out.
But this idea of a universal
database that has audio
fingerprints of music, and
people can go claim that, and
then other people know
who owns it.
Or if nobody is claiming
something--
I talked to a guy from the IFPI
who said he was working
on something like that-- like
universal identifiers for
songs so that people know what
it is and what the rules are
associated with it.
And then he emailed me again,
and he was like, I'm getting
fired, and I can't talk
to you anymore.
ALEX WINTER: Yeah.
The NSA showed up at his house
and dragged him away.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Possibly.
Who knows?
But I don't know.
Do you have any hope of
something like this?
I guess content Id on YouTube is
kind of like that, where it
just knows this song, the
money goes to that guy.
This song, nobody wants.
ALEX WINTER: Yeah.
I think that what's
interesting--
I remember I was hanging around
with Fanning a lot when
he was working on SNOCAP.
That was predominantly when I
was writing the movie the
first time.
So I was in the trenches
on that, and
watched what he was--
And it was amazing, both the
courage that he had.
And then he had Hilary
Rosen on his board.
It was really an amazing
turnabout from what he had
dealt with before in that he
had a lot of support from
within the industry.
People that had villainized
him were aware that he was
actually trying to help
solve the problem.
But it was just brutal to watch,
because it was just way
too much too soon to
try to do that.
And I think it's
still too much.
I think one of two things
is going to happen.
I think actually both things
are going to happen.
I think that companies like
Google or YouTube within
Google are going to make-- and
already are making, I'm sure,
behind closed doors-- are going
to just make humongous
strides in this area, because
they already have their arms,
like you were saying about
Napster-- they already have
their arms around the community,
which is the lion's
share of the battle is just
getting your arms around the
community and going, OK.
We're all here in
this one space.
Well, we're all in YouTube.
I mean, that's a fact.
I mean, there's no comparison
between their metrics and the
next metrics down
from YouTube.
It drops by like a billion
or something ridiculous.
So all our arms around that.
So they've got a really good
shot at driving a lot of
reform, because the
numbers are there.
But I think we also can't rule
out the disruptive innovator
who comes just clean out of left
field, like you're the
person you're talking about,
who just comes up with a
better mouse trap.
And that's what's exciting to me
about the landscape that we
live in where you have that
capability, where someone
could just come out a left field
with a better mousetrap.
And that would be great, too.
And in this day and age, it
would probably be acquired and
it would then be folded into the
pre-existing system, and
the world would be happily
ever after.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
I should mention that we have
microphones, if anybody else
has a question for Alex.
So here's one.
So Google Play All Access is not
the only service that does
this, but it's one of them,
where you can take MP3s you
may or may not have gotten from
Napster over a decade
ago, or from anywhere else, for
that matter, and upload
them into a service that
pays copyright
holders when you stream.
It's a legitimate service,
and I think iTunes
match works that way.
Sort of amnesty.
Welcome back to paying
for music.
And you can still bring all
that other stuff that you
have, and you're forgiven, to
quote the band in the movie.
Do you think that the kids--
I mean, if you've grown up with
free music at this point
in various forms, do you think
that as kids grow up, they
will start to pay $10 a month
for something that just gives
them access to everything,
including the stuff that they
get elsewhere?
ALEX WINTER: You know, I get
asked this all the time.
And I'm beginning to think that
I must either be totally
naive, or I don't know what.
But I would understand that
question in 2002.
But in 2003, Steve Jobs proved
the answer to that question,
which I knew in '99, and the
Napster guys knew in '99.
And the guys that created
the iTunes store
all came from Napster.
I mean, Jobs literally hired--
I won't name names, because it
always gets me in trouble,
but, I mean, you could
Google it.
He hired this guy, this guy,
this guy, and this guy from
Napster, who had built the
artist development, the iTunes
store, the head executives over
at what became the iTunes
store at Apple.
So people will pay
for convenience.
Of course they well.
We learned that in 2003.
They paid through the nose for
convenience, and they continue
to do that.
So again, in my experience,
we don't live in
free culture anymore.
The free culture window was
really, really short, and it
was through necessity.
We had a free culture window
because when these
technologies erupted, they
erupted outside of the purview
of the industry.
So there was no way
to buy this stuff.
You could only download
it for free.
There was no way to use Napster
and pay for it.
They were desperately trying to
play catch up and make it a
pay service, because they
weren't going to make any
money if they didn't.
They were using the model
of like, here,
take all this stuff.
It was like a beta model.
Take this stuff for free, and
if you dig it, then we'll
start charging for it.
Well, they never got there.
So iTunes did that.
They made a fortune, and they
built the empire that is the
new Apple-- sort of Apple II--
off the back of the fact
that the public will
pay for this stuff.
So my son, for instance--
my older son--
he never grew up with
free culture.
He's always paid for
content online.
He didn't grow up during
the downloading era.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah.
I think people view it as a
waste of disk space now.
Why would I clog up my
whole hard drive?
ALEX WINTER: Yeah, but even if
you're working off the cloud,
he'll pay for Pandora,
or he'll pay for--
and actually, a lot of people
like having stuff.
Like, my son specifically will
be like, I don't want my stuff
on the cloud, because
it gets lost.
Or if my internet goes down,
I can't listen to my music.
So he likes having stuff.
Drive space being what it
is-- and that's about to
revolutionize anyway-- that
won't be as big of an issue.
But still, you can keep an
enormous amount of music on a
thumb drive, and kids
love doing that.
I mean, he's got it on his
phone, on his laptop.
But he'll pay.
I mean, he does everything
on YouTube.
If YouTube--
and they're doing this with
advertising, obviously-- but
if they literally turned around
and started charging
him a subscription fee for
YouTub,e he would pay it.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: You
guys hear that?
ALEX WINTER: Like that.
I mean, honestly, he doesn't
want to hear the ads on
Pandora, so he pays.
I just don't believe we live
in that culture anymore.
I never really viewed the
public as thieves.
They wanted to convenience.
They didn't want to steal.
As soon as people started
offering them services that
were as convenient as the free
services, they paid for them.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
So Lars Ulrich features
prominently in your film for
obvious reasons, and I got to
interview him I don't know if
it was two or three years ago
at South by Southwest.
Under heavy security,
by the way.
I don't know if you
dealt with that.
Like, there's the Metallica
police or something.
ALEX WINTER: It's
like Disneyland.
They have their own
police force.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah.
It is really like Dethklok.
So I just wondered, so, during
that interview, he admitted to
BitTorrenting his own most
recent album at the time.
ALEX WINTER: Oh, I saw
that interview.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: So from the
artists that you talked to,
did any of them sort of off
camera tell you different
things about Napster?
ALEX WINTER: You know, that
happened all throughout
Napster's history.
There was always a duplicity
between what was being said on
camera and what was being
said off camera.
I mean, I did so much research
when I first wrote the script,
and almost all the artists that
I talked to in those days
used Napster and dug it, but
were really scared of their
labels getting mad at them if
they said anything pro.
And I think you would still find
that 10 years later, that
a lot of artists wouldn't go on
record for fear of reprisal
from their record labels.
I think that in Metallica's
case, you were dealing with--
I would say to be fair to them,
they were the front end
of the very beginning of
people going, holy
crap, what is this?
Like, there's this tsunami.
What is it?
Can we just stop and figure
out what it is?
Which I think is actually--
like, to be fair to Lars, is a
justifiable and understandable
perspective.
I think what happened to Lars is
that a lot of artists that
may have been pro or con
Napster, whatever, once they
knew what it was, were like, oh
my God, what is this thing?
And Lars went running out onto
the battlefield thinking he
had a whole army behind him,
and then turned around and
everyone else was like,
no, I'm not
getting involved in this.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah.
They probably saw
those cartoons--
ALEX WINTER: Yeah, exactly.
And there he was, and he stuck
his neck out, and nobody came
to his aid.
But I think the reality of it is
that if you look at Dre, or
you look at Lars specifically,
Dre was certainly very vocal
against Napster, but it's not
like he was a Luddite.
I mean, look at how he's
primarily made his living for
the last 10 years is primarily
through digitally oriented
headphone equipment, and is now
sort of driving forward
beyond that into actual music
based subscription service
technological hoo ha that
he's doing, much off
the model of Napster.
So I don't think that these
people were just like, no,
we're never ever ever going
to evolve with these
technologies.
I think that they were just
completely blindsided by them
and wanted to sort of stop
and address these issues.
But the reality of it is you
can't stop these technologies.
You can't stop evolutionary
technology.
You can't.
It's unstoppable.
So you have to run with the
train and make the reforms
that you need to make, and
I think people are
still adverse to that.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Right.
Well, unless anybody else has
questions, I'm now going to
ask the inevitable one.
ALEX WINTER: The one I probably
can't answer.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK:
No, no, you can.
Have people have been file
sharing your film, and have
you seen that happen?
And how do you feel about it?
ALEX WINTER: Oh, yeah,
of course they have.
As soon as we were available
digitally,
within however long--
two hours after that--
we were DRM stripped
and on Pirate Bay.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: At which
point you completely reversed
your philosophy and started
suing everybody, right?
ALEX WINTER: Yeah, yeah.
I think stealing content is
fine, unless it's mine is
actually the conclusion
I've come to.
Yeah.
I mean, look.
Again, there is a lot a debate
about this, and there's a lot
of emotionality around it.
A lot of ignorance, I would say,
and a lot of really just
hurt feelings, too.
I have a lot of friends who
are musicians who are just
bummed that the industry is
not the same anymore.
And I get it.
The industry isn't, and
it never will be.
We're never going to reset the
clock and go back to the Tower
Records era.
It's never ever, ever,
ever going to happen.
So I'm not callous about that.
I think there are things that
we've lost that are a bummer,
just like change.
The horse and buggy-- we didn't
have as much pollution.
Maybe more methane.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Methane,
I was going to say.
ALEX WINTER: But there
are always
sacrifices when change occurs.
But I don't think that there's
anybody sensible in positions
of power anymore who doesn't
realize the promotional value
of torrenting.
I think I read an article
yesterday where the guys at
HBO are getting more
vocal about--
even like the "Game
of Thrones" thing.
Like, they'd rather people
didn't take it, but I think
that those people are becoming
aware of what the reality is,
which is as soon as we're able
to match the convenience of
these free services, people
will pay for them.
And I think that's just
been shown over and
over and over again.
And you will always have some
degree of pirates within that
pie graph that's a very
small percentage.
The bulk of the people when
you're dealing with massive
torrenting, honestly, are not
getting it as conveniently, as
quickly, and in a more
legitimate service.
So yeah, people are
downloading it.
I think honestly,
for us, on our
level, it's just promotion.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: Yeah.
I mean, I think you're
onto something there.
It's the motivation for the
industry to evolve in a way
that makes more sense for
the fan or the consumer.
ALEX WINTER: Yeah, absolutely.
And what just got leaked today
or yesterday, I was
reading about it?
Whatever.
Some new show or whatever got
leaked, and the response even
with that was like--
I think it was the premiere
of "Homeland"?
Something like that.
It was like, it's
really actually
going to drive promotion.
They were just at that point.
And if you watch this,
historically, it's sort of
like the witch trials.
It used to be heretical
to say this.
If you said this in public,
you were blacklisted.
How dare you say
piracy is good?
And when that kid got thrown
in jail for a year for
uploading the Wolverine movie.
And then subsequently, if you
actually dig into it, you
realize that it did incredibly
well for the movie
promotionally.
And I think some poor
sucker's doing time.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK: It's like,
this movie's so good that this
guy went to jail for a year?
ALEX WINTER: Exactly.
So I think that people
are beginning
to realize two things.
One is that a lot of that stuff
just drives promotion.
And the other is that the public
is not inherently free
culture people.
I think the idea of free culture
is total mythology.
I don't think we live in that
world at all, and I think it
just keeps getting proven over
and over and over again that
people will pay.
ELIOT VAN BUSKIRK:
Nicely done.
Well, thank you very much.
Alex Winter.
ALEX WINTER: No, thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]